on prime crime if you had killed susan
would you tell me
our continuing story of robert durst how
do you know kathy's buried at all same
psychological step
from his unforgettable testimony to an
ending you may not see coming that is
absolutely ridiculous i don't understand
it at all that rule should be revised
[Music]
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime this is where we
do a deeper dive into the most high
profile and memorable true crime cases
this is part two and the conclusion to
the robert der saga
previously on prime crime this is a
gunshot wound to her head that means the
killer had to be near her susan would
not allow a stranger into her home i
wouldn't spend a lot of time together
in common
susan berman was killed in december of
2000 two months earlier the westchester
district attorney's office was reopening
the investigation into kathy durst's
disappearance
that spooked robert durst you know about
the the call to the dean right i don't
think cathy galt the movie and
andrew was under the opinion it was
susan berman susan berman was killed
because she was a witness and had
evidence against robert durst for the
killing of his own wife susan told me
that she'd been contacted by
los angeles detectives
and new york detectives
and who you sent it to susan vervin
1527 benedict canyon beverly hills
california beverly skelve so obviously
i'll ask you about the cadaver that
would save the story did you write the
cadaver
i was the worst fugitive in the world
has ever met
he
moved to galveston texas
morris get out of here he takes the gun
out i grab him and the gun and we fall
down in the kitchen the gun goes off and
shoots him to the side of the face
i'm gonna have to dismember his body
he told morris black about janine
pirro's investigation that became a huge
piece of evidence of robert durst's
motive for killing morris black
i think some of the jurors were swayed
by his celebrity and his wealth what
made you do the movie still sort of
putting that together in my own mind
of course
on the eve of
the episode of the jinx airing he was
arrested
i do cold murder cases complex
circumstantial murder cases this is
really the case that never ends
hopefully it won't end until justice is
achieved
when robert durst is arrested in 2015
down in louisiana he doesn't realize
he's about to meet a new adversary
starting in 2013 the district attorney's
office in los angeles reopened its
investigation into the killing of susan
fuhrman a prosecutor
in l.a who specializes in cold cases
named john lewin was assigned the case
i feel like i know you even though i've
never met you
i believe lewin's strategy going into
that interview was to let robert durst
know that john lewin was the world's
leading expert on robert durst's
favorite subject which was of course
robert durst your brother doug is not
your favorite person was that a fair
statement that's fair then they ask you
the same question do you remember what
you answered
it is still my my favorite my favorite
thing that i've heard you say
durst treated the interview like it was
a game
if you had killed kathy
would you tell me
no if you had killed susan would you
tell me
there were so many moments where he just
seemed to be
skirting the things he knew would
incriminate him
when you killed susan
that was not something you wanted to do
i'm gonna stay away from killing susan
if durst didn't kill either susan or
kathy what was this exchange about
if i tell you
what i know okay that answers your
questions
what can you possibly do for me okay
he wanted something from lewin a
non-prosecution agreement for giving
some information
at this point in your life
would you have an interest in um
saying what happened and telling
her family if there was something i
could do
for
her family okay
and it would get me
then it would be worthwhile for me
john lewin did not give that deal
but he did get the admission that indeed
hey i may be able to give you something
in this case we have a very
determined
experienced and hardworking prosecutor
we have our work cut out for us
coming up the unpredictable and bizarre
trial of robert durst
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
if i go ahead
and fight with you
and let's say i win
you're not going to win
after 20 years robert durst finally
found himself on trial for the murder of
his friend susan berman this trial was
unlike any other not only was there a
14-month delay that interrupted the
proceedings due to the coven 19 pandemic
but the prosecution was permitted to
introduce evidence about two other
deaths to connect durst to berman's
murder that of his missing wife kathy
mccormick durst and his former neighbor
morris black
he killed kathy durst
he killed her
and then he got rid of her body we will
show that when the reinvestigation
happened
and when susan berman told him
that you know what
i'm going to talk to investigators
did she seal her faith
the evidence is going to show
that he murdered his friend morris black
dismembered his corpse
and he did that
because again
morris black
was
when it came to durst defense he did
something shocking admitting what he had
denied for years
you agree you did not just find susan's
body and somebody else killed her did
not find joseph's body
bob durst did not kill susan berman and
he doesn't know who did
he did find her body
shortly after someone had shot her in
the back of the head
to begin with you didn't write the write
the cadaver note does that work
whoever wrote that note had to be
involved in susan's death
he panicked
he wrote the anonymous letter
so her body would be found
and he ran
he decided he was going to tell
his story he was very good at telling
his story a lot of times and getting
away with it and his story was i just
happened to come upon my friend susan
berman and therefore i wrote a cadaver
note and sent it to the police
the defense also argued away durst
infamous bathroom confession on the jinx
bob durst is an easy target it wasn't a
confession at all the producers of the
jinx had come along and spent maybe a
hundred hours
interviewing bob and then splicing and
editing that together to make him look
evil
at trial there were many notable moments
like when defense attorneys reenacted
the morris black shooting uh mr mr lewin
why are you describing i can't see it so
we've got we've got mr garen
playing um mr black
or the tense call between one of durst's
friends and prosecutor lewin
we believe you've got information
maybe
and then there was the testimony of
durst's friend nick chavin who claimed
that durst made this chilling admission
i said
he wanted to talk about susan and bob
said
i had to
it was her or me i had no choice
yet there was one part that we all
waited to see when it's 78 years old and
suffering from numerous health ailments
the accused murderer robert durst took
the stand
did you kill susan burma
no
do you know who did
no i do not
i had the opportunity to interview two
of the jurors it's interesting they
slightly differ in their impressions of
durst on the stand
he would talk about things in such you
know detail where
gosh you know how could anyone go into
that much detail unless it was the truth
if this is the same testimony that he
gave to the texas jury i could
understand how they would find him
credible
did you actually see her get on the
train
she was standing on the platform
with half a dozen people
a train pulled into the platform
the doors open
now did i actually
see
kathy
walk through the doors
onto the train
and the answer is i don't know
maybe he might be you know telling the
truth and some of these things and just
like you know that documentary was
called the jinx yeah this he is the the
victim of the worst luck anyone has ever
experienced
i shouted susan a couple of times
her eyes were closed i put my hand over
her face
and it felt cold
if somebody had done this to somebody
maybe he was still here
he was giving answers that he had
already practiced giving they just
looked very rehearsed like a performance
my voice
is very
recognizable so i decided
instead of calling 9-1-1
i would send the police a letter
there's something to keep in mind about
durst testifying in front of
you did lie to the juries in galveston
in some way that your lawyer encouraged
you to and
it encouraged me to
uh
we went over the oath in terms of the
whole truth
if you were to leave out something which
makes you look bad well
try
up next the incredible cross-examination
how is anybody supposed to figure out
when you are telling the truth and when
you're lying
they would have to use their life
experiences
for the whole
long weekend when i did the interviews
for the jinx yeah i was on some mess
okay i'm a straight shooter what you
just told me
is
in 2021 the world watched in awe as a
frail and sickly robert durst took the
stand in his trial for the murder of his
friend susan berman a crime that
occurred two decades earlier durst
claimed he found vermin dead in her home
and then panicked and ran away
did you have any motive to kill susan
berman
no
was susan blackmailing you
no
while the prosecution argued durst
killed berman because she was a witness
to the alleged murder of durst's wife
kathy mccormick durst the real estate
heir denied having any knowledge about
what happened to his missing spouse and
he even suggested she was a drug addict
who got into trouble
he also was adamant that he shot his
friend morris black in self-defense
which a texas jury agreed with as they
acquitted him of murder in 2003
but then it was the state's turn to
question durst and there was only one
man for that job
how many instances of perjury do you
think you have committed during your
testimony in this trial
i'm right around several times
prosecutor john lewin just delayed him
i've never seen anything like it i
believe the killer
was either still in the house
or in the yard mr durst haven't you
testified that susan's body was cold
i did not testify
that susan's body was cold
do you have it you ever ready to go or
not
play it
see if i can feel breath
and it's so cold
well what do you have to say about that
her breath fell her face so cold
her br she's dead how can her breath be
cold when she's dead she's a stiff
i could have watched robert durst on the
stand in the susan bourbon trial
with john lewin
probably forever it was the most amazing
cat and mouse game
i think i need to congratulate you
you've just broken your personal record
you filled up 18 lines on my tablet
and i want to congratulate you you've
set the perjury record
i had a
full clear view of the side of his face
he would give like a little sort of like
a playful
smirk to john as as if he was
challenging him
i never said i knew
stop
why did you say
you never said you knew where kathy was
buried how do you know kathy's buried at
all
same like a logical step
i brought up
that my wife was in this program
atlantic's hill hospital
that was supposed to help her get off
her cocaine
mr durst
look what's number one the program she
wants to go to is lennox hill hospital
oh she was already there
yes as a drug addict patient
i guess the interview would have gone
something like this well doctor why
do you want to join our program i've
been very impressed oh have you worked
here dr durst
no actually
i'm a patient i'm in your drug rehab
down the hall
um
gosh i hope that's not going to affect
my chances will it
after 15 days of testimony robert durst
finally left the witness stand
when we return the controversial finale
to the durst saga
think all court shows are the same we're
talking about your father guilty or not
guilty guilty think again judge caprio
rules with common sense i was having
contractions i was rushing to the
hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand jail
and compassion i'm going to take the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had clearly
judge he's been in a court before
get caught in providence
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre law and crime is
the only network that has it all good
evening and welcome this is a
complicated case don't really jump to
conclusions welcome to prime crime
tonight another day of drama between
both sides from multiple live trials
daily to original and compelling
programming the law on crime network is
everywhere and we invite you inside the
jury box this is law and crime
did you kill susan berman no
but if you had you would lie about it
correct correct
september 17 2021 that's the date that a
verdict was reached in robert durst's
los angeles trial for the 2000 murder of
his friend susan berman prosecutors
argue durst killed berman to cover up
the alleged murder of his missing wife
kathy mccormick durst in new york
after over two decades with all the
conversations the interviews a movie a
documentary and an interrogation we
would finally get an answer as to
whether robert durst was in fact the
killer
we the jury in the above entitled action
find the defendant robert durst guild of
decline the first degree murder of susan
berman
the fact that he
admitted to being you know in that house
and you know discovering her body and
the fact that yeah he was probably there
within you know minutes or even at the
same time as you know the real killer
was
that has no credibility for me or for
the rest of the jury at all if here's a
person
who has you know
inadvertently you know confessed his
explanation where
with somebody else it just it's
unbelievable
we further find
the allegation that in the commission of
the above offense that susan berman was
a witness to a crime
at the end of
this discussion about kathy's murder
we did not believe that she was a drug
addict who
went missing or ran away we felt that
the evidence demonstrating domestic
abuse and murder was
overwhelming
and this led to a unanimous guilty vote
and this supported the special
circumstance
susan berman was an extraordinary human
being
killing her was a terrible loss to our
community
it's the judgment and sentence of this
court
mr durst that you be imprisoned in the
state prison for the term prescribed by
law that is life in prison without the
possibility of parole
while durst learned his fate in
california there was an unexpected
development in new york
that conviction had significant
implications for our office's ability to
bring charges
after almost 40 years robert durst was
finally charged with second-degree
murder of kathleen mccormack durst
however the prospect of justice for
kathy would be short-lived
we have unbelievable news robert durst
who was convicted of killing um
multiple people charged with multiple
people he has died
when i found out that robert durst died
my immediate thought was that robert
durst willed himself to live as long as
he did he wanted to be
the center of attention at his trial
with that complete
i think he was done
the greatest sadness that i felt that
the news of robert durst's death was
that we would never learn
what happened to kathy durst's body
yet there's an important legal
implication here not only will durst
never stand trial for the murder of
kathy but in california since durst died
during the appeals process his murder
conviction was dropped
that is absolutely ridiculous i don't
understand it at all that rule should be
revised all this effort and energy and
resources went into establishing this
why can it be overturned and
nullified so easily i do take comfort in
knowing that there was you know great
satisfaction in giving that guilty
verdict because it was a long time
coming especially after he was acquitted
in texas
most people are not going to be looking
at this little detail that it was
overturned i think
the message is that he
was finally found guilty
and that's what's going to stick in
people's minds
after all said and done robert durst's
worst enemy was robert durst his
interviews and testimony it all helped
show who he really was and what he did i
think the best place to end is actually
with a statement from robert durst
brother douglas after robert's death
this is where he said quote bob lived a
sad painful and tragic life we hope his
death brings some closure to those he
hurt
that's all we have for you here on prime
crime leave us your comments on
instagram and twitter with the hashtag
primecrime as always thank you for
joining us and until next time be safe
[Music]
you